19:45 in germany has lost world war two
with them lost the Austrians having
found themselves thoroughly Angelus in
1938 Austria was occupied by Allied
forces much in the same way that Germany
was the Soviet Union was placed in
control of this territory in the United
States Britain and France getting the
rest the Allies have declared Austria to
be the first victim of Nazi aggression
and thus they technically weren't
occupied but were liberated from a
social standpoint post-war Austria was
in a strange place
whilst the referendum to join Germany in
1938 wasn't exactly a fair one many in
Austria did wish to remain a part of
Germany and were still sympathetic to
National Socialism in the Soviet
occupation zone life austrians was
miserable Soviet soldiers were
responsible for about 90% of all crime
in Austria in the years following the
war furthermore the USSR also relocated
much of Austria's wealth away from the
country by moving factories and seizing
Austria's oil in the western occupation
zones things were better
they generally ruled with a light touch
and when a bad winter wrecked harvests
and the Austrian economy crashed they
gave economic aid however this wasn't
exactly a wholly benevolent gesture the
cold war was just beginning and so the
Western Allies were seeking to win over
the Austrians to their way of life and
deprived the Soviets of what would
likely become another puppet state this
fear of communism spreading was
important when deciding the fate of the
former Austrian province of South Tyrol
the Austrians and the majority of the
people living in South Tyrol were hoping
that the two would be reunited as they
were before World War one the British
and Americans were deeply concerned that
taking too much territory away from
Italy would increase the popularity of
the Communist Party there and so South
Tyrol remained a part of Italy the
Soviets had at first placed a socialist
Karl Renner in charge of Austria when
the nation went to the polls in late
1945 the Conservatives under Leopold
fieger won feigl decided to present to
United Austria in front of the occupiers
and invited the Socialist Party to form
a unified government without off chef as
Vice Chancellor Austrian leaders now
denounced the notion that Austrians were
somehow German despite the fact that
Rena had been very Pro Angelus before in
fact the notion of Austrians not being
Germans led to many German Germans being
kicked out of the country whereas many
non German Germans like those who lived
in the Sudetenland were allowed to move
to Austria Austria also went through the
process of denazification which saw half
a million of Austria's former Nazi Party
members placed onto a national register
in 1948 the process of denazification
was ended when the majority of low
ranking party members were given amnesty
the amnesty was largely a political move
since those 500,000
former Nazis made up a large voting bloc
both main parties wanted their votes in
the future that said even with amnesty
most former Nazis were forbidden from
holding political office by 1949 the
Austrian government wanted their
occupation to come to an end this didn't
happen because Cold War the problem with
pulling out of Austria was that there
was a potential for them to fall into
either the Soviet or American alliances
Austria was itself a Western democratic
nation but one that was all too aware of
the fact that communist Yugoslavia
Hungary and Czechoslovakia lay on its
borders he was Austria's position
between the two ideological bloc's that
forced its government to be a perpetual
coalition of the conservative Austrian
People's Party in the Social Democratic
Party internal party squabbling ended up
getting rid of filin he was succeeded by
julius rabe who made sure to improve
relations with the USSR rabe began talks
concerning Austria's independence with
the Soviet foreign minister of
vyacheslav molotov and its new leader
Nikita Khrushchev in 1955 the state
treaty was siding it was agreed that in
return for the withdrawal of Soviet and
Western forces Austria would ban all
fascist parties and was forbidden under
any and all circumstances to ever
literally ever unite with Germany it was
also tacitly agreed that Austria would
become a neutral non-aligned nation they
set the stage for Austria's place in the
Cold War in the modern era it would be a
nation whose past was to largely be
ignored for the mean time and whose new
family treaty would soon go on to shape
its national identity perhaps the most
important legacy of the decade after the
Second World War was the Austrians
would-be Austrian I hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
Anna special thanks to James Bissonnette
ozark a flash Henry Robin Winston Cawood
Adam Harvey and Skye Chappell
you